[Music]
rainbow six siege is supposed to be
about slow and methodical play
oh this isn't looks like a rush it's
going to be a rush cycle is already in
kills the echo easy kills take your
kills most days as well
so he says i think there's no one to
hold this push siege is supposed to be
about strategy and skill
not just aggression but one region
didn't care about
any of that looks like a complete
downstairs push here for bathroom
team liquid gonna get a lot more
aggressive than expected here
wow the like of the smoke we're gonna
get him yes ness will take him out
liquid are running away with us here
they used every tool at their disposal
to rewrite the rules of siege
they rose they fell and they rose again
and they did it all
their way nip take control of the lower
bracket
and the second spot in the grand finals
of si
2020 cg sports has pretty much always
been dominated by
europe and north america and since pro
league started
these giants have developed a reputation
for being tactical geniuses
right so they seem to prefer on border
they prefer top bomb side defense first
and then vents secondary
so on armory lockers they go mirror
smoke jaeger bandit
these methodical masterminds dominated
the game
and even as new regions entered the fray
it seemed like the established regions
just had too many advantages to be
toppled
i mean every every region has their own
unique style of play i'd say europe and
north america are the two most close
but that's because they practice with
each other for the longest i mean think
about early seasons in rainbow six like
i remember
season one when we had north american
teams coming over to europe
and north america teams had like no
strats they would scream uh european
teams
at a land event and suddenly strats in
north america the problem was that siege
was
isolated every region played separately
for most of the year which meant that a
region like
adam rarely got a chance to play against
the world's best and when they finally
did
it didn't go very well you're gonna see
a dual peak here
they're gonna say look for the corners
gonna go one two three they're gonna go
for the shots and he misses one he's not
gonna look for the sky but he gets it
and now it's gonna be fabian
getting the win for his team this is the
grand final champions and we are gonna
see penta
win this all they are the world
champions right now for season one
we saw an early latim uh incorporation
into pro league
that uh they struggled atlan at
international land
because it's a very different style of
playing and it was something they
weren't very used to
the brazilians didn't play anything like
the other regions they were more
free-flowing and aggressive if europe
and na were like classical music the
brazilians were like
jazz their strategies are a lot more
loose or at least they seem to be from
an outside perspective
more based on synergy less based on set
strats
if we find a latin american team will
just kind of go at it
brazil had tremendous talent but they
just
couldn't close time and time again they
found themselves not outgunned but
outpaced outmaneuvered out strategized
twitch and iq it's gonna be you can won
can he snag what he got you getting that
one can he get the clutch here on the
uke
he knows that the last man alive is
going to be yuki knows it's iq
he knew he doesn't have an interview he
just needs to play time
can he get it he's got to move in this
could be the clutch of the century here
shuttle
he's got three seconds to go he can't
find him
it's gonna be elevate and a huge misplay
by brk
and then in march 2018 an operator was
released that would change rainbow six
siege forever
now if you're interested in the full
story behind lion and how he
literally broke siege we did a whole
video about it you should check it out
but for now all you need to know is that
this wall hacking operator let the
brazilians boost their already energetic
style
they turned it up and people loved it
it looks like a complete downstairs push
here for bathroom team liquid gonna get
a lot more aggressive than expected here
wow
what's the like of the smoke we're gonna
get him yes ness will take him out
liquid are running away with this here
oh no the push from liquid in the back
penguin will get taken down
a sexy kick rushes in and there's just
still more
ken dallas being shot in jonas cannot
see a single thing as that
gets through more on the board here
brazilian slash latin american meta is
the most aggressive
period they take fights more often than
anybody else they have some of the
probably the best mechanically skilled
players
in any region and because they are so
aggressive
that a lot of teams that aren't used to
that they don't know how to handle it
you just feel like you're getting
overrun being bombarded
and you can't you can't fight against
them because they're going to out aim
you
you can't outpeak them because you don't
know where they're coming from in fact
thanks to their unstoppable aggression
team liquid took down
penta the greatest roster to ever play
siege in the season seven pro league
finals
fabian last man alive the in-game leader
on the lion will
is lying here to fight five good luck
fabian everybody from team liquid
concentrating their efforts
you see everybody every single one of
the players here concentrating on the
one kill that they need
have they run it
but then season eight happened and
pikman was introduced
and everybody was banning lions so the
brazilian's hyper-aggressive playstyle
ate a pretty big nerf gas canister to
cover that drop down it's still doable
but he's got so
little time he gets a third he's going
for it gcr
the mvp of the round now in a one versus
one but he's not gonna be able to clutch
it
gcr the final kill and payne take the
match
6-1 the issue is that brazilian players
wanted to stay aggressive since that's
what got them results in the first place
that meant that they had to play one way
at home and another if they wanted to
achieve any sort of success
internationally
right now i think the biggest issue with
latin america is that they're focusing
too much on their own meta and not
enough on regional competitions
you have to be prepared as a region to
take on teams from apac from north
america from europe
and if you don't adapt and get ready to
do that you're going to be in trouble
now
the tough part about that is that you
still need to be really aggressive when
playing
other latin america teams in your own
region but you need to be able to
translate that to other regions as well
that's something that phase and liquid
and somewhat immortals have been doing
really well is that they're trying to
straddle that middle
but it wasn't any of those teams who
took brazil back to the top
for the better part of two years the
region's most notable rosters
fumbled and flopped on the international
stage in spite of their domestic
dominance and some truly stellar
individual performances
when it mattered most they crumbled this
could be it
drone watching constantly pinging 30 hp
sexy cake right up against the window
he's running out of time he's going to
bait it out now he's sticking on
for a little bit longer two seconds
scyther just need to jump in and shoot
and slide
here shepard is off site grab the
diffuser and plant
but above the man who is always last
alive has the marks he knows they're
there
but he can't out duel the beam he gets
him at the last second
and latin america that's their swan song
here
in raleigh he's completely blind he
hears one
he engages can't do much takes some
bullets to the side it sticks there from
coverage and 9xt is outside
and they manage to forward faze clan
despite adversity stacking up against
them
so by the time the six invitational 2020
rolled around hopes weren't all that
high for brazil
but little did anyone know brazil
actually had a killer roster at the
event
it just wasn't the one anyone expected
it to be nip is going to circle around
and go to head on in
e1d gets burned members of g2 will drop
the sophia looks to play against the
mute two kills for ninjas in pajamas and
that's it
ninjas in pajamas a spectacular victory
2-0 over their european opponents
you see unlike their compatriots the
players on ninjas and pajamas actually
felt for a while that latin american
siege needed an overhaul
we had a really good style aggressive
style
and then people knew that you know and
then they encountered it
i think the latin scene got got a little
lost because
brazilians like to say they are not that
organized so like
from time to time we changed that and
now we are we can beat the other region
only 20 seconds left for that plant it's
a stick stick from rafael so a
one-on-one
effectively here psycho wins it and now
another one on one as we fell to the
post plant
there it is 4k
and ninjas and pajamas the 7-4
taking the map and the series
europe's gone led out forward
a lot of north american and european
fans thought that nip had come out of
nowhere but
they didn't these players had been
playing together for years and they were
actually the first latin american roster
to make a pro league grand finals
psycho is also going to try to drop here
kamikaze gets goga
fabian on the refracts the kamikaze
psycho drops he picks it up
there's only two members left from penta
it's fabian it's not panko it's now five
and it's all up to him
and a one on two julian and wag can he
get it fabio's gonna dip around the
granny won't get it
julio gets the frag black dragons goes
to the grand final
what's more they didn't play like
brazilians
nip were absurdly versatile sometimes
you'd catch them playing cold and
calculated siege
a push a nice kill from kamikaze shotgun
out he will relocate he doesn't know
where they are
inside of the lobby there's the buck two
for kamikaze it's sir boston at 1v1
but kamikaze only has one hp he'll go on
upside down repellent this is an angle
that will almost assuredly net a kill
against kamikaze
brutally challenging if all but
impossible for the smoke to be able to
land
kamikaze knows this he's inside of the
bathroom he will for just a moment
distract
sir boss tossing in a smoke canister
will that be any damage
no sir boss has to get out of there
he'll need to re-aggress
down goes a flash pushed off is the
smoke at the doorway
no way kamikaze clutches that out
other times they'd spot an opening and
be on site in 10 seconds
very early control over to nip that's a
free one as well walking right in what
is this
pojo man doesn't realize that they've
lost the control
because of the fact they hit the combine
oh no pino with another lineup moose he
won't get the kill
here comes the rotate though and it's
caught off this time nip
taking full control right from the start
and tsm
doesn't even know what happened they
weren't reliant on aggro rushes but they
also weren't slaves to the slow and
methodical style of siege
they could switch between calculated
european siege and yolo adam siege
whenever they want it
brazilian teams are a lot passionate
they are emotive no we
we are emotional too but we are our
mindset is like
perfect right now for like to win this
turn you know
you can ring rounds lose rounds like
urban set is the same
and there are a lot are strategies too
you can play passive you can play
defense you can do a lot of things you
know
nip were so successful because they
weren't limited to one tempo
they were masters no matter what pace
they were playing at
they can't hold them back for much
longer they've only got 15 seconds left
here comes the push pino's ready to hold
the line is he ready for the road take
from logi though that's the next
question
yes he is he finds the polo frag and
kamikaze is ready for the final push
n.i.p take control of the lower bracket
they claim victory
and the second spot in the grand finals
of si
2020 nip ran the entire lower bracket
and the invitational landing themselves
in the region's first ever international
grand final
and they put on a hell of a show that's
quite a lot actually with one shot but
oh a bad peek
pino reads it perfectly lands the shot
and a big kill
for ninja pajamas thanks to the nade the
rush from hino gets the triple kill and
there's the quad
beautiful play from the buck flash is
going in will somebody be able to watch
fultz it looks like he has them caught
from the back
he gets a second kill it's on dupino
psycho takes out rampi
pistol out and there's psycho he sees it
there it goes
almost gets a second no damage done but
rampi will not be effective he gets
hunted no way
it's that 30 seconds away they need to
find
one person that's it he'll head in
towards archives and get caught space
station gaming
are your world champions and even though
they weren't able to close it out
it didn't matter they made the run of a
lifetime they scared the living [ __ ] out
of literally every other team at the
tournament
and they earned their region the respect
and prestige they always knew they
deserved
we always knew we had the thing to to
win you know we always knew
that we can do it but like we didn't
deliver
it in other majors so this one we are
delivering
our confidence is like as high as
possible
of course due to covet it may be some
time before nip get to prove themselves
on the world stage again
but until that happens they've been
dominating domestically
they came out as the clear victors of
vladim's august mini major
we'll see psycho slain pinot trades back
here comes
the human uzi the massacre is way
through takes himself to 12.
one final frag is all that's required
nip
they win the major they will be crowned
the best
in brazil no matter what comes next for
ninjas in pajamas
they've made one thing very clear
brazilian siege is back
and it's better than ever
caller's also funky
brian probably hated that because he got
it's got the worst noise he's ever heard
in his life
just really appreciated me like
fidgeting with the with the microphone
[Music]
another noise brian really probably
hates to hear